welcome to the recruitment radicalize
support cast my name is Hisham Aziz
today I'm joined by Jamie Fraser who is
the director of a recruitment agency
called inter X who are a Microsoft and
cloud specialist agency yeah got that
right a second time Jamie thank you for
joining me
yeah and we're in to set the scene we're
in the heart of London in Bank
how long have been in this office this
is on Cornhill about a year now
really yeah okay cool and how many
people do go out there yeah fifteen
fifteen how many how many people can
this fit this office we will get
probably about 35 people in here yeah
okay by the end of next year talk about
where he was last year that's where we
are and as I was as I've sent you mate
before and we're always like to start is
how how the hell did Jamie Fraser get
into recruitment may share the story of
us how did that happen
left school didn't really like school
from one interview wasn't the type of
person that's they say enjoyed being
told what to do all the time yeah yeah I
left school quite early actually and
I've always been warned I've always
wanted to work always had a drive and
ambition to want to do something where I
wanted to be like the best that I
possibly could be fell into recruitment
I was applying for actual generic
banking jobs at the time before thangkas
met loads of money off wasn't I didn't
have a clue I was young I was young and
the company I went to read at the time
was actually doing an intern which I I
took on yeah Dundee internship and it
went from me without so that's how you
ended up in recruitment mm-hmm okay
where did the sort of you know you just
always want to work and be the best you
could be whether that come from what was
it that was that influenced by your
parents at all or where the dad that's
interesting because how many I'm sure
you've met loads of people and of course
you were going to meet so many people
that don't have that yeah you know I
mean where where did that where did that
come from so I've always relied on
myself to drillings don't get me wrong
like my mum Hill has always helped me
out as
they do I've always everything that I've
done I've got myself in life really yeah
so you know I've always been the type of
person I want to be the best at anything
like those super competitive yeah
correct
really you know people talk about
competitive but they're not you know
would you you know like they say oh yeah
I'm really company I've interviewed
people that say I'm really competitive
rah-rah but there's no real facts behind
it yeah everything I do has to be the
best you know I've got over CD I'm a
perfectionist and really think I do so
everything has to be at a higher
standard and you know like I say
anything I do do in life whether that's
Paul non-sport whatever it is I want it
to be as best it can later and that has
that just come natural to you then yeah
really yeah that's interesting
mm-hmm okay so did you realize that you
so when you ended up at Reed yeah did
you realize like you as a plan for
recruitment job at that point or they
did they just speech about luck said I
was young at the time how are you I
think 17 I don't I didn't really think
write recruitment yeah you know same
saying my brother my brother is he more
criminalize of recruitment business too
and he he got into recruitment via Meeks
he was doing letting we never knew yeah
or was we just fell into it because a
lot war was real perception that point
it she had a no perception at all
nothing really
yeah so you worked at just a framework
for everyone listen and see what she did
it was an internship three months Reid
yeah just like candidates all candidates
with banks crap now look back is it was
the worst experience ever really I
didn't really learn much there from
those of you yeah yeah didn't learn much
there left there I'll be honest with you
back back then I was quite still cook
could have called me semi nervous shy
really yeah yeah a hundred percent left
there and you know I must have
interviewed at 20 25 places really
didn't get a job in any of them and and
it was a crippling job recruitment jobs
you know they put it down to nervous you
know
and started quite a lot too young and
list went on really yeah a lot of a lot
of the big recruitment companies that
actually tried headhunted me headhunting
me when they saw I was a global tour
Billa was that they actually interviewed
me previously and said no that's
interesting yeah it's a lot of people
doubted you mate yeah that's difficult
feed that you wanted to be the best
surely do you think no really I you know
it was what it was I'm you know that was
my situation and people didn't like the
age people didn't like my CV people
didn't like you know how I come across
an interview and I'll you know in I want
great interviews I'll be honest with you
yeah that's interesting yeah how did you
land it so and then and then you joined
the recruitment agency and then how long
was you there for I joined Nigel Frey
yet the director got Alex Williams yes
who trained me and I know pretty much
yeah yeah it to an extent he he he was
the person he believed in me trusted me
really you know he gave me gave me that
chance basically and you know underneath
him he really did grill me not grill me
he drilled into me of how to be the best
recruiter ever really yeah why did you
think and gave you a chance I think he
said at the time that you know he was
like me back in the day sort of thing
actually like he got he got a chance and
they're not yeah yeah he saw a lot of me
in him and then he gave me a chance
anyway I'm was this in London yeah yeah
okay because where did where did you
grow up I grew up in Essex in Latin and
then what's the read was read local and
other stuff before I've done recruitment
but yeah yeah it's just an odd Oh chap
and Carmen we grew up now but was in
Essex but he said like literally you
could ask anyone this it's and they've
all done recruitment at some point I've
got a lot of Essex boys
[Laughter]
okay so then just to frame up then so
how long did you work at Nigel Frank for
top of my head about nine months nine
months and then you joined another
agency No
so okay story was I left I had personal
problems yes I you know I went to live
in Spain oh really yeah I went to live
in Spain just wasn't really getting on
at home okay so I went to live in Spain
with March my dad used to live and yeah
I don't I just went away for a bit and
then that whether all those skins from
me who loved Spain but then I come back
and they really the way I got to hunt a
charge that Alex set up Hunter Charles
oh is that the yeah and you know I
didn't have loads of experience why Alex
know they've got would get from me is
I've build up the market quickly I've
build on the market you know I had the
intensity I had to focus mmm and he no
no you know I'm very hard-working you
know when I was at Nigel Franco I was
training in the day yeah and you know I
was you know doing a lot most cool times
most called dials the input was there
mmm because I worked hard never missed
about it's not it's not me like I
respected my situation yeah you know
also him giving you a chance as well
yeah you've respected that that wasn't
really coming into my head really more
to do with you know if I'm working I'm
working that's just me from fruit yeah
fair enough you know when I'm at work
I'm at work I'm no [ __ ] about mmm
okay so then is it feds and then how
long was your hunter Charles I think
three years and then after that you
started into the correct so let's just
talk a bit about hunter Charles for a
second maybe you can include Nigel Frank
if you want but obviously the clear that
was your sort of real grounding where do
you think that things happen personal
whatever but ultimately that ended up
being like your real grand and in
recruitment which saw loads of things
you learned through that process led you
to this point have you starting on
recruitment business so I guess you can
use hundred Charles or neither Frank but
how I'm always interested speak to you
about how their first 12 months were and
recruitment because there can be some of
the toughest then all we've experienced
now on plumpy
but that can definitely be the toughest
for quite a few people particularly
people that gets old recruitment is as
we said on the phone that they did when
people sale recruitment typically it can
just be about the good things the money
you can earn the things you can buy do I
be four trips you can go on but don't
talk about the rejection that you can
face on a daily basis these sorts of
things I guess
how are your first 12 months in
recruitment yeah I think you know Nigel
Frank was more about learning learning
learning being drilled in that process
you know it's a very s freetype culture
in terms of militant old school you know
this is it if you don't like it you're
gone you got your thing and you either
work that way you don't start it's as
simple as that and so that they cut they
car you know they cut the crap out very
quickly and I alex has the mentality of
you know hunch miles are now off this is
the way we do in you know the proper
recruitment way and that's where I
learned a ruthlessness really him yeah
what does that mean talk to me about
that what was that ruthless he took no
she took no [ __ ]
really yeah in what sense there like
when in what sense when your people take
the peace then you know they don't know
about it but that that's what I that's
what I like about Alex is you know he
you know I don't get wrong like I get I
always got along with Alex because he
knew that he could rely on me and the
end of the day however there are a lot
of people to take a piece of recruitment
so you don't you talking people that
work for you like yeah just in general
like you know employees you know they
want to sit on their phone all day you
know they they want to take the late
lunch is they want to belay and you know
it happens and if you're not drilling in
a culture then it's just gonna all run
riot right no you know I learn a lot
from him put it out like okay how did
you do so well from what I saw online
[ __ ] if I'm wrong the market he ended
up in is now the Maquis being in for
yeah like since 89 years yeah so how did
you do in terms of the market out at so
and there's always a founding consultant
always contract below yeah they're done
a little bit of plan here and there but
that's just cause client there was an a
job I knew the candidate I didn't ever
work
heavy there has been predominant
contrast a little spin on my contract
will prefer oh yeah okay cool how do
balloons wasn't a first year mate
remember my first year I think I've got
to 5k a week yeah and then what about
Hunter Charles is that well Charles
so I've done a couple of deals ones that
Nigel Frank went to Hunter Charles and
you know I was there found in consultant
they got bought out by commenting
alternate international who are like a
glow like they're a big IT recruitment
guy in Australia probably the market
leader in Australian occur there's a lot
of back in I would say number one
employee you know between the London
office and UK they had like a hundred
people plus in the first year or two
really yeah they grew very quickly
I was working very closely with Alex at
the time to grow grow to brand would you
start the market from scratch then yeah
really yeah yeah yeah so I left at 16
and a half care week that's that's what
I've got to when I was there you know
and you know my background is is BD I
don't rely on accounts and stuff like
that so you know one month I mean I
don't like ten deal was in a month all
new business catalyst cap to six months
you know stuff like that people people
you know and that was an account that
wasn't accounts coming to me that was me
going to them getting the jobs get you
know working jobs being a specialist we
just talk about that for a sec just
because if I think of like the most
common things that people ask me to talk
about with guess it's business
development yeah it's winning new
business yeah so love the fact that
that's something you're really confident
in and clearly yeah I'm good at it
yeah let's break that down a bit what
what sort of now as well I guess you can
think about obviously what you help
people with now in your business but
against on the market from scratch from
what undersides important so I was a
planned recruiter and so from what I
understand sitting down with people like
you yeah from what I understand contract
is very much if you could if you get the
BD right yeah and you're really good at
that you have every chance of definitely
well so let's break that down for a sec
so you so how what would you say are the
some of the biggest contributors to you
being able to open ten new accounts
when in 10 new clients open a court of a
killer impact opening a call of a killer
impact yet talk to me mate what you men
people people work the cheesy way too
much okay in terms of asking and you
know you know I ask you know literally
you're never ever ever going to get
information from a client if you ask
them so you know some some recruiters
will ask about jobs they'll ask if
they're hiring mmm instead of putting a
twist in it and telling them I heard
you're hiring mmm is that way and that
was them to doublethink and then go get
the information for you because
sometimes you know like I said with the
killer impact site side of things is you
know who we are who I am you know what
we do who were helping and then pitching
that way mmm people people can't open
you know when I go up to my floor now I
could go it's my flan get them all to
pitch me now all pitch me the same
because we all I drill into them how do
we make sure the first 10 seconds a
client said it's right honest on the
phone to this guy that's really
interesting it's like it's like a
personal pitch personal pitch is perfect
really yeah it sounds so basic about how
many people were like in the recruitment
market now for you it's a put him aside
and go right if you're talking to you
for the first time in your pitch that's
interesting that yeah give us a holler
but was that tip of consist of his life
I'm on a mission Mizzou's I'm calling
because this this will Who am I yeah who
are we yeah what do we do mmm okay a
case study of a testimonial okay and
explain how we're helping a testimonial
as quick as possible and then speaking
to him about how we can help them as
we've been helping other customers it's
more like case study base that's
interesting you know we're moving away
from that typical recruitment style
we're moving towards the more
consultative approach offering solution
mmm that's what we're doing we're not
doing a tipple called cheesy recruitment
I don't like the word of recruitment
anymore really and that's why we're a
staffing company were especially
staffing company when people are saying
right you know this is what we do I want
to speak to HR or I want to speak to
line manager and do
typical flipping back references and
stuff like that asked us yeah I want to
get big projects big juicy projects
where we can do five ten fifteen condoms
as in okay let me so if I'm listing
right now on I'm going Jamie totally get
that
that's really interesting what if I've
got none case studies right now I'm just
you know I mean I'm doing but they go
they go I learn the case studies they've
got right yeah learn learn who are we
working with working Microsoft is one of
the biggest testimonials you can get mmm
okay cuz obviously if you think you're
building up at so you are you sending
what leverage what because if your agent
if you're working for an agency right
now and they haven't got any
testimonials you know I mean that's just
what I'm thinking that's all for new
stuff yeah yeah like if well if
someone's been a decimal scratch yeah
and they're going through this right now
and it's like you know what like I'm I'm
trying to build never just the company
they're really but then if you then say
okay why there's no brands okay but then
you can still open with a killer impact
take the picture which is offer a
solution based consultative advice of
how we can help you compared to a
standard agency and more of a
consultative agency mm okay standard
agency is okay what jobs do you have
selling candidates a consultative
company like us will find so we work
with a lot of customers we will find
problems within their projects where we
can offer our services how can we save
them money
now can we consult Satan time to to
deliver the project easier bends on
quicker people don't do that I know that
I didn't my competition don't do that
and that's why you know I completely out
build all of my competition mmm cause of
that reason that's really interested in
that so if anyone listening like and
then you know you said about that pitch
there I'll really like the way that you
structured that like surely that's got a
bit lost and more than 10 seconds but is
it the beginning make sure that they
know who am I talking to
not for them to turn around say okay who
is this or what do you do you they
should know exactly who you are with
that killer impact and I think also as
well like tonality confident when you do
that is Hashem passion really yeah yeah
people call me arrogant sometimes I've
been called that once I being called
arrogant in my interview okay
I don't put it down to arrogance okay
arrogant is someone who is very cocky he
doesn't have the facts and me I put
myself down sir
passionate with facts this passion that
may make me sound like okay yeah he's a
bit arrogant but no hmm because I'm very
passionate you know what I've done I you
know I'm not grateful but I'm proud of
my achievement so there yeah and like I
said I put a lot of it dance of passion
and you know I told him all to pitch
with passion passion goes a long way
than that I think it's the best thing in
any pitch in mmm passion energy light it
would just taste it would take you long
it would take you a long way understand
so a big part to how you got to those
sorts of numbers new business and that
is that something you like new business
you always got new business every single
month she was like right what new you
know our 90 percent of my call was a
success or if I make the call that's
interesting
yeah and is it anything before that
though to make sure that the calls you
are making are procedure being an expert
I don't know like an article my LinkedIn
or what is especially a grocer hmm okay
no in your market mmm ie who are the
biggest projects in your market who are
the best candidates in your market the
top 20 candidates in each job tile in
your market okay knowing when you get a
lead who is the lead for and they being
quicker than your market you're like a
competition you know I've done a deal
with every continent in the world now
okay I just start this year in January
with on my last deal which was which was
Australia mmm you know I've done Africa
Australia Asia Europe North America
Canada and South America and you know
you would think that my competition in
these locations should have beat me they
did hmm
so is there any is there so what how how
come people really start getting to that
point of really knowing their marketing
so that was a big part of that knowing
their candidate so you can give you this
information of what was you not cut not
kind corners really candidates say you
know I was in a car net guy the reason
why I've got the reason why I know the
best kinda star placed the best
candidates mmm it's not always to play
you're not always able to place the best
candidate
however I you know when people interview
with me people work for me
my clients mainly everyone knows I'm
just direct and I don't mess around and
not you know and talk the cheesy way of
recruitment and listen I don't I don't
care about that
yeah bottom line is I don't care about
that for me I want to do business I'm
here to do business and that's it hmm
surprising like it sounds simple but how
many people were doing that what a
cheesy nod doom wanting to do business
and being directs and solving problems
and you know I mean a lot of people
don't ask the questions I'm a call to
let's say you know a lot of people are
afraid sometimes you know when you're
flipping back a project manager and
you've sold a project manager a job if
it's a fake of a real job and then
asking about their higher needs even 18
people think people just forget the
basic sometimes hmm so you just
mentioned now I'm thinking so you're
someone that and did really well with
this business bill out this book of
business how you knowing that you wasn't
should obviously candidates and how did
you deal with that then cuz that's
something also you had to be good enough
at to had good jobs okay that's
interesting is that the difference in
the contract market then there obviously
that will not I don't mess around my
candidate along and don't go give them
feedback mmm I don't do that
like I say the reason why I'd done well
a lot of my deals were jobs I created I
found problems of him projects and sold
in solutions hmm that's creating a job
and very rarely chase leads Michael that
is BNC jobs
I want exclusive a jobs mmm you know my
ratio at my last business was like one
point one to a deal really yeah where
does mindset for this fee fit in because
I feel like you strike me as someone
that it's clearly got work then natural
work ethic mine says K right you know I
pray I tell my team of that mindset all
the time yeah you know I've thought I'd
do research on one set and really dress
and everything over there may be good to
just talk a bit about that because I'm
sure lion said you've got a tough times
it hasn't all been [ __ ]
I'm point one Jan I mean like when I
first set up my business yeah I lost all
of my money really yeah
I lost all of my money doing the same
stupid if I wanted to I should I could
have just gone back to my old company
and earn all that money I was only
monthly but I didn't I pressed on - its
key I never ever ever let something
affect me one I'm working
never regardless how bad it is so is it
safe to say it would never go on to that
because nothing like that I love the
fact that you've been open honest about
that was it out hunter chosen work was
there more ups than there was downs then
no because like I say when I was on
target end it was a month before I was
on I think five or six deals one of the
boys in the team at two weeks left when
I was he said are you can chill back and
sit back now yeah don't wrong I build
big that big numbers there and I was
like nah no way yeah I said watch I said
watch what I do this month and you know
last week I created a couple of deals
because you know I just made it happen I
thought you're not my name there was no
I only get ten yeah I can be talking
through ten no you don't hear a lot of
people to do ten deal with new business
deals not count delivery and all that
share I mean I proper new business there
was and I pushed on you know that
someone that's an average of crew I talk
about comfort zones as well you know you
have to comfort zones
you had the Grove stones always in my
growth zone always want to learn more do
more be better your podcasts have you
caught overrated that you know I don't
get me wrong right
as I've got old I've got more
intelligent about you know I'm not a
brightest person yeah I got it
not a lot of GCSEs however for me I'm
very street wise and you know I'm all
about mindset positivity everyone that
walks through my door gets gets given a
book a secret really yeah that's
interesting you know we've got another
book called gung-ho I was recommended to
me by my Ned which is just great about
the secret because I've read that and I
mean that's that's a summations every
day you know much my trainee he was the
quickest shiniest he'd do a deal with a
month and a half he's done two deals a
month and half no recruitment spear
it's no sales experience Eva and you
know I you know he watches like Eric
Thomas and stuff like that so you know
my whole business is built around now
all the negative people of just I've got
rid of them mm-hmm let's dive into your
business yes I'd really like to do that
so clearly learned a lot of Hunter
Charles if you always want to join
business Alex knew that I always wanted
no obviously didn't like it but you know
I was you know I was a big bit I was
then I was that man below mmm I've done
phenomenal numbers that if I stayed
there was there a point that where you
like know what I could be doing this for
myself
knocks I was young right a lot of people
doubted me are you too young to the
races 23 when you started set up
interests at 23 yes and who who
typically would be like now Jamie need
more you need more experience mate was
out because was that friends was it but
your colleagues are there when I handed
my notice in Australia what we do mate
yeah really
that's fine though you know but did you
did you what where the whether that
motivation to starting to read Scott did
it come from anywhere was it you know I
mean don't really know because I've
never done management training I never
managed a big team ever oh it never was
a mentor people that's interesting I
mentor people but every everything that
I've done and Zeo I've learned it from
Alex or I train people how I do
recruitment you train people how to do
recruitment and you know how I work yeah
I am very militant I'm a one-off and you
know I've liked like Alex always said to
me you can't hire yourself I always
wanted myself you can't hire that and
and I've only started getting my head
around it it's not every bill is gonna
be amazing
yeah however my expectation is through
the roof yeah okay so interacts you
started that in when he was 23 28 2016
April 2016 and like what did you have a
business plan like what was the what was
the plan here mate did you have a plan
had a plan but I've never done anything
I'm just a good bill oh really a lot
talk to me bit about the early days that
make because I think I've you know it
was it was pathetic look it up look I
still have it now
came back back here saying about one
deal a month after month I don't know -
I said to myself oh my month 1 I put a
bucket on a do a month to the end of the
year 12 months yeah that's pathetic
that's not that's not a lot yeah I
always done worst case and all of this
and I'll be honest with you it's quite
embarrassing looking back it however no
I didn't know any different I knew I
could earn money on my own that's the
first 12 months were bit challenging
Nokes are done well however I did have a
big challenge because one of my projects
went from what my product so completely
for product ok got rid of all of my
contractors however you know I didn't I
didn't have a plan I just said to myself
right this is what I need okay
in terms of tools not I just needed a
phone and LinkedIn really you could do
and that's all heard on business by
mm-hmm where did you where was you
working out I had a small which is
probably the size of this half of this
meeting room in lauter mine where I live
was there grew out of that straight work
so I wanted to hire someone with you
went to another office in Lausanne where
I had one employee yeah and then we come
up to here Bank Bank we went to the
office group yeah was there for a year
hated it and then yeah we leased this is
this was a big commitment that we had
done it okay so a lot of people there'll
be a lot of people listening that may
think about what hands that have wanted
to do there and recruitment business in
these Tysons business often love him
nothing
what do you mean nothing no cash in
jetted funds I'm a sole founder of this
business right I said to save that money
I lost most of that money gambling yeah
really yeah wasn't just hasn't like
socially gambling or was in gambling I
like so everything I do is either big or
not big everything okay
when I go out everything it's all I ever
do it all or nothing
mmm okay that's just me in my business
I'm all or nothing mmm you know I put so
much passion in my training it's
ridiculous and people know and have come
into a training session with me
you know I it's just just who I am and
you know people people will say you know
what you know do you need this massive
plan in place do you need this you need
that know if you're on your own
pick up the phone and do the job well
make it happen yeah stop looking for
excuses mmm it's embarrassing how did
you know used in obviously there must
have been obviously quite a few times
really am i doing the right thing that
because you got nothing else to really
you've got none to bounce off that's
obviously some song people worry about
that of course and it's so hard
none I think 80% of people won't be able
to do it maybe even more 90% so what got
you free that than me who I am
hmm I told you like I say all so much
focus and discipline and passion and
determination and you know the list goes
on that like I say that I'm not to do
the job
nothing will stop me hmm how did you get
this money back that you lost their main
I had a little bit of money yeah I got I
got my own face which was cheap but got
my links and recruit arms it's not it's
not only expensive for me I had my
phones that's all I need I don't need
job boards nothing okay so was when so
the first time um was it you said it was
just year he said just to trap back just
use it yourself and louder no the end
you've got saws you know got someone in
here so that was interesting and so
hadn't you mentored a few Peters like
the big drive around you wanted to get
someone in because I was super busy
really yeah in a space of 18 months I've
got my contract but my own one to 20
1,500 a week really and and is that that
Jamie been really good at new business
again is that me maybe Nathan I knew my
competition right Nigel Frank
I knew my competition in my market and
I've output with everyone now and I
don't know anyone there maybe I don't
know mm-hm I don't know anyone has had
zero database zero anything and zero
brand and to build to that number
quicker than me mmm
18 months no database nothing
again to 21,500 away billion 84k or
whatever it is I've not heard anyone do
not bad that has a no something to be
proud of
yeah exactly 100% and I know you just
said this before we started and then I
think it's a good thing to know
and this wasn't in the UK at this point
this was ahead or mainland Europe or
manual and then like I say you know and
did you do that when he was a previous
company
yeah UK and Europe and some state staff
as well but when I was here I focused on
Europe
really I had covenants as well mmm all
new business that you don't know
everything
mmm I tried saying it wasn't it was try
coming after my new business stuff and
it was just really it was pathetic but
yeah so with that in mind mate how so
then it's a didn't sorry year two at the
office great how did you grow to then so
we we were classed in our four years
riots like 20 2017 was our four years we
started halfway through 2016 okay 2017
was out for four years yeah that was our
first full year than last year was our
second full year in this Salford four
years all yeah so you know in the space
of you know in a second so in our first
four years to give the end one of my
biggest accounts completely they got rid
of all of my contractors and about 15
contractors in there okay
she's free quarters at my book Wow yeah
so it was it was like oh my god what's
going on mmm just after Christmas as
well really yeah I remember it oh [ __ ]
yeah massively because you got
understand right we didn't have a lot of
cash
I was billed in because was you sorry
again because this isn't and what I
worked in but with contractors does it
was you paying them out of your nowait
or did you ever have the payment we had
hey we got a finance agreement with HSBC
okay cool yeah so then that involves
them pay rolling and play fat sexual in
a paid us woman was paid well no the
client was me just normal like we have
it yeah
okay how did you learn to turn olive oh
cool
so the chats um where did you go from
there then like you lost all those
people pushed on really yeah it's not
starting again yeah not starting again
never fall back Quinn really I know I
know I'm the best at what I do
mmm there's not that you know what did
you learn from that they don't focus on
one account what didn't focus on one
account so I've done a busy so
everywhere else but don't let it be a
percentage well then sometimes you think
you're not gonna turn away business
right in your market mm-hmm you know I
was doing deals I know tomorrow there so
that resilience you're talking about
there hmm
like everyone out there so there's what
15 did you say 15 now all of them all of
them can't have that real resonance that
you have like how have you gone about
cultivating that and your lot of them do
now
Mike or 10 hmm they do have you but how
do you build out for them because that
that's if I think again gone home
message me a book yeah would give us a
bit of a synopsis just a core thing
talks about from culture Hodge it's all
about culture we in the last six months
we've really created our culture I'm
trying to create my brand our identity
you know our training is debate you know
I think it's but the best in the
industry you know the training comes
from me and I'm mentoring people of how
how to you know I've built up to content
books from scratch no bran muffin and I
I am mentor people and how to build
quick better than a competition master
fair competition and good and good you
know I'm 26 a lot of energy mmm you know
my trainees wanna work for me and
trainings don't work for my competition
in the industry because they know
they're looking at me 26 year old that's
gonna turn over 9 million Ishi and
compared to maybe a forty fifty six year
old CEO that I don't have much
interaction with mmm you know it's all
well and good saying yeah I've done it
20 years ago that was easier than it's
so much harder now and so much harder to
recruitment now what do you think a good
contract below should be billion that
erect canvas I suspect someone who
worked for a decade for 17 years
build 1.4 million in one year and but
and then it I was a bit in there 14 2003
he did that but and then I said but in
today's market totally different like
yeah I'm completely different now blah
blah blah and he said he he fought a lot
of really good contract but it can do
anywhere between sort of five to seven
hundred now and today's market a great
below
yell a decent contract look and those
sort of numbers my top bill is 22 he's
gonna go into next year on 15k a week
who should be in about twenty K by April
really yeah and then we're sort of what
does it add up in like a year then so
that's just me Ben so I'll let you think
just because I've seen million right
yeah it's just cuz normally poem it's
like the year like June I mean this the
year we really yeah so culture is
something that everyone talks about
let's just talk about that so you said
they're like the last six months you've
really been trying to see loud can you
start identifying that if I'm listening
right now how can I start identifying
what my culture is you know I mean okay
we some classes like semi corporate but
semi this is a proper sales company okay
okay
I have now got it to a point where new
people will come in so we're doing it
well I don't a training academy loss to
three months ago yeah two months ago
yeah these were brand new trainees and
we've now got a culture where any new
person with their senior or junior
comments our business that my core team
are set in the pace they're not at that
level they'll get left behind shy away
core culture is set now where we have
rules we have ways of working we have
processes not a lot of people have this
in place okay
you know we I'm all about creating a
noise in the office okay and the culture
that we're building is that like I say
people will know straight away if
they're right for it or not and you know
we we will be outside that I can
identify were in the first week of
someone's kind of last here because how
differently they work to how we we work
as a team and I oxide we work all the
same my team's ranges 18 to 20
May 26 and we all work the same way as a
team and I want to press on a team
because you know there's a lot of
businesses where everyone's very
different and you know yes it's good to
have people that different however the
way of working the processes in the
structure how could you start building
that then if you didn't have that before
but I have an EDD and I can accept
director ok he he caught me in a book or
he told me to get the book and Tommy to
read in you know a big impact it has and
I spoke to a couple people ways of doing
things and you know you know Pete people
have left my business that I've got rid
of you know they always say oh you know
very very militant way of working and
stuff like that but you know you've been
true to yourself there then it's me
being true so when people get what they
see with me and I'm very direct in my
interviews people come up interviews and
say I'm just so direct but that's
because I will never set make missile an
opportunity there's a lot of people that
miss sell opportunities in this industry
I'll never do that people will know
exactly how I am the pressure it will
get from me but with me I get results
out of people mmm that's the difference
if you want to be average you won't work
for me mmm okay if you want a challenge
and actually own a shitload of money and
beat everyone in your industry
you work for me there's no two ways
about it and that's why the same way in
any interview that I have mm okay if you
want to be average go work for someone
else cuz you won't be welcome here
because my bar is higher but that's
because you know I was the best in my
industry I know that for a fact
and now interest is a brand I want us to
be the best at what we do mmm and that's
why I and you know like say I'm such a
perfectionist in everything mmm
everything I do has to be perfect
hmm and if it's not then I lose my [ __ ]
that's because you know I want people to
know in syrettes is the brand of quality
I love that may you're so passionately
talk about that and often I think again
dupa is someone's gonna listen saying go
now what I want to work for him that's
fine but as you just said it's like the
people that do you want that the people
out there that are do because there's
not everyone wants to strive for that
nice don't do you know I mean I don't
know I thought
that's all the things honestly I think
that's great the fact that you're owning
that averages and welcome with me yeah I
just love the fact you're owning that
cuz it would be like like I don't I
don't be rude I don't be arrogant like
if yeah like if you want to be the best
work for me but like you're owning that
you know anything that's great you know
all my training training academy people
that i've got i closed him on the spot
mmm because they knew that was sold an
interview they didn't have to go home
and think about it
they know what it was stepping into mmm
you know i interviewed so many people
the ball was so high for the trainees
and you know i got i got the right
people I haven't retained one person
because he was it couldn't take
criticism but I've got four people out
there that I couldn't beat machines in
the next year mmm absolute machines when
you're hiring obviously its data it's
obviously a real challenge for a lot of
recruitment business and for their own
business what are the sort key key
traits that you look for in people that
also undergo snowboard that they have to
have so we're looking at more trainees
at a minute and trainees they need to be
moldable moldable they need to be
passionate and they need to be very
positive mmm they have to have the
mindset of wanting to work ridiculous
hours okay I'm not saying you have to
here I care about results and the input
but they they need to have the mindset
of one year you know okay to work hours
is they need to work ethic yeah yeah I
think everyone's gonna say that though
right but I can tell straight away if I
want or not
MMH I mean how could how can you measure
those types of things an interview what
earn affinity tip typically do that some
people might be able to get a value out
of I just know what I want
no I know I want and I could say people
buy into me I'm not cheesy guy that
hasn't been there done it you know
trainees look up to people like me you
know I don't get wrong I love spending
money I love spending money I hate the
word budget budget doesn't even come
into my office because you know when I
do mine sense is their top there top
right there you can't get better
mmm and people know that you know my
incentives are great you know I do an
incentive nearly every other week okay
and I don't care about doing that people
all you spent too much money okay but
we're getting results that does dusters
my philosophy hmm
simple as that so as you as you
mentioned it a couple of times so I've
had the conversation quite a few times
with business owners and have said
around sort of them wanting to get in
there dan these types of things yeah how
how impactful was that being for your
business mate yes I got scary goldsmith
yeah 19 industry yeah it's been great
work he's helped me out a lot would you
say if people if an agent is listening
right now and they're thinking about
getting there whatever what are some of
the things that they should maybe think
about or some of the things that you've
seen the real benefit in your think with
me right I've got no background in
building a company yeah sure YUM okay
I've not got any real real management
experience okay I've got no process
where I'm looking at forecasts and stuff
and peer no I've never done any of that
okay I put a structure in now I've got a
structure and we can build on a great
structure we're now scalable that's the
key word right we we're in a position
where we can scale scale yeah and like I
say we're in a position where we're
scalable because we have the right
culture in place and that's an and and
having an EDD has really helped you
marty'll with that yeah that's it again
I think what you're saying there is huge
value add is that if you're someone that
as you just said you're something that
recognizes some of the weaknesses
something experiences you haven't had
and you can have that to someone that
has those experiences then that's super
valuable I can give him a call when I
want mmm yeah and that's enough in
itself yeah because if you have any
mentors never Alex mentor to you yeah
not now we don't really talk now but
yeah he was he was he was great on the
money part the money you talking about
you love spending money yeah yeah
obviously just again I'm an honest guy
right and it's come up a couple of times
it come up and Oakland was on the
conversation recently had in this
podcast
how much so what do you talk to anyone
about managing their money well being
smart with their money just for example
you got eight so my top bill awright he
was he he started on a decent money yeah
he wasn't he wasn't his mom and dad were
telling him what to do
I said no way yeah I actually told him
it's a [ __ ] ignore borough and just
start spreading it enjoy it don't come
and graft your ass off and in watch it
and you're young and watch about how
much you're going to spend on a top or a
pair of trainers I don't like that okay
I just think there's a conversation to
be had around there's also I think a
hundred white light if you think you
young mad earn good money
yeah just mentioned gambling their
little whatever but I'll give you a nice
big conversation than that so
you know what people get with me when
they work for me is that they get a full
package they get their may their boss
director colleague whatever you want to
call it yeah
I'm everything to a lot of people out
there and I go the extra mile to make
sure that everyone is comfortable in
life okay
whether that you know me helping someone
out with counts at him I don't care I'll
pay for it whether that's you know just
being there for some when it when it
your things that [ __ ] I you know that I
you know whether that's you know I had
one guy that was in riddled in debt but
I was paying it you know I've managed it
I was managing his money in the end you
know I had his money I was managing it
and yeah it was a [ __ ] pain in the
ass hmm but I'll do that especially if
they work for me I don't care what I'll
do I'll do what I can to make my team
happy mmm okay I'll go do some I'll
because like I say I'm just one of these
people where people can rely on me mmm
yeah you said that from yeah talking
about this yeah again to be interested
to get your thoughts on this and the
context of the time we've got a bit Mme
where is happiness fall into this mate
does not mean I know what you mean
obviously money money does bring what
you'll see in your journey of happiness
during this business because how they
just getting this me and you today I
feel like you clear someone that's all
about work as you said it fully
committed when you hear about
blah how was that impacted yeah your
relationship with happiness they said
ups and downs how does it impact
relationships with with girlfriends
partners whatever do you not I mean how
how's that been it's really like your
recruitment business there things you've
got to think about I'll be honest with
you gone whatever the situation is one
business comes first
yeah yeah that's what uh there's no two
ways about it not no one is gonna get in
my way on what I'm gonna achieve I don't
know because what I'm going to achieve
is gonna be phenomenal I know that
because you know there's no one like me
and I can say it because I I've got you
know III confident your people when
people meet me and they day that they
can see straight if they've worked for
me they think you know I I'm good at
what I do because of how I am and who I
am I'm happy you know I can spend money
when I want now I've never been out to
do that and you know you know my mum
even said the other day she spent a bit
of money and you know she was she was
ice she was like happy because he's
great that she can she doesn't have to
think about like what she has to spend
okay so seeing stuff like that he's
great money - regardless what anyone
says money brings happiness okay because
you get to do what you want
you know I'm 26 years old right I've got
businesses earning a shitload of money
okay I'm earning a shitload of money you
know I've got everything might possibly
one okay yeah I might want to get a few
other massive things but asked millions
of pounds I need to be spending but for
a 26-year old I've got everything I want
so yeah I am happy hmm don't get wrong
I'm stressed out my however you know
I've got a good team behind me that
that's handle all of that stuff you know
I've got a good you know team that I pay
and I think it's all you know I'm very
healthy
okay like a circle oh she knew
everything and yeah I've got you know
I've got a good scene of helps me with
myself in different areas you know I do
yoga every way I'll get a massage every
way to get acupuncture every way you
know I
in money right of course you know yeah
is but you know and in the way you know
one of my health advisor says if you
don't do all of this and take an hour
and a half at lunch to go gym then
you're not gonna be at your full game so
if I'm at my fall game I'm not gonna
give then my four percent and then my
business looking at four hundred peers
no point if Jamie isn't like you can't
give a hundred percent of Jack's money
is not gonna help you do that however
I'm in early I leave light I've never
taken a piece I'm never late I'm never
sick so that's me I lead by example
mmm always have always will mmm I would
never let my last company ever it's
important I think yeah it causes in that
yeah people look at the news this
meeting the meet you mean you just
speaking on new I'll come be like this
mean you know I love that I think that's
class so just a quick one as we finish
me and just to find the light sort of
what you'd learn and stuff I think
thinkin of the people listening like any
any sort of learnings on you helping
these guys get to the bar and the
standard like a work were shown and now
you mentioned the book a few times but I
don't know and any song have a go have a
goal every you know have your
affirmations written down so on my phone
right I have and my affirmation is
written down on everything that I'm
going to achieve telling myself that I
will be successful
dealing myself do I achieve X Y Zed
every day I read that every day
regardless every year I have a call
mmm every month I have a go mmm okay and
you know people ask about me you know
what's your two year free if not four
year plan I don't have one mmm was every
year we always over achieve and I always
would do everything I can to overachieve
so have a goal written down and affirm
that every day done that's so so so big
you're not setting yourself that every
day give up just give up or start yeah
start yeah they just just start doing it
start being positive you know people
aren't like that
mmm you know I've got a lot of people on
that wavelength since they've started it
and they love it it is mental again I
was the wig going off was talking about
this sort of stuff in my office of eight
and I was the weird on the office light
I'm positive I'm again long
it goes it was its the possible possibly
the most biggest thing right now hmm or
this positivity and you know and I've
read you know being being negative
actually shrinks or your your your mind
I don't know what it's actually called
but you know being positive it allows
you to to think better over think I've
been being negative it actually makes
you narrow-minded as a fact like a
scientific fact yeah and III drill
people on that every day mmm hundred
percent if people comes in negative I'll
bring them in here and I'll find out
what's wrong mmm so when it done gone
can you be positive all the time that
yeah do you think it's mindset mindset a
lot but I think my business plan on
mindset mmm we all we all believe in it
but it's okay I've personally I couldn't
agree with you more Bobby okay every day
I mean you have [ __ ] things happen yeah
how'd you leave that at all yeah it's
how you manage it like the end of day
that's the thing when you really realize
when you have a [ __ ] day at the end of
day when you realize you have the choice
how you react to that that's how you
manage it is how I manage it for them
yeah I help them that's what that's what
I'm here to do is to be a mentor to be a
coach to help them be better you know
change their mindset tailor it mmm you
know what why why is that irrelevant
right now why is you know giving 100
cent when you cannot come out of this
meeting room mmm you know relevant no
that's what people need to think about
is how they handle it and I've always
handled it well hmm but I'm learning
more and more about mindset and it's
number that because I think it's so big
so big so important do you still bill
now or you always I get on the phone
dear
yeah I've got enough fun every now and
then really yeah and I'm not gonna beat
BD director really yeah then what we
doing the rest of the time my managing
vision training stuff like that on the
business and getting more of you people
but like I say I'm trying to bring in
like a number two if anyone's interested
you have to be positive
yeah because I want to focus more on you
know generating some big accounts and so
like this year I've brought on Microsoft
in multiple locations that's great
but I want to stock it you save your
strength about 90% my calls client calls
are successful mmm you go into that cool
really my feeling and knowing that I
know that I'm gonna get so nasty because
I know what I'm gonna say I'm gonna give
them testimonials I wanna I'm gonna hit
with my pitch it's my pitch and you
can't have this pitch because it's my
pitch and this is how I do it because I
can back myself up I can send you know
clients to my LinkedIn page and say oh
I've got 41 references on my LinkedIn
page clearly I'm doing it right mr.
client mm-hmm okay
and like I said a lot of it's about you
know letting them to trust you but trust
comes with proof mmm if they don't let
you prove it and what's the point having
a conversation where's this business
going then what's the what are you
thinking about where you're hoping next
year next year we'll have 35 people we
have an office in Amsterdam we will in
the next two years will be the market
leader in what we do in Europe for
quality not biggest but quality will be
will be the best in Europe how important
his head count to you the right head
count yeah no I'm glad you said that
again conversation I had with a chap
like if you were to ask him yeah a year
and a half ago two years ago he's like I
want to be 30 50 whatever heads in he
said it was I got caught up on head
count the head counts vanity and I don't
have a big pot of money we're just dip
into everything I've done is organic so
many growth so everything I do is very
careful yeah yeah no I think that's
again if you think if you go down to the
pub and like oh hey Jamie how's business
going the first thing they go Marsha is
how many people do or how many people
work for you may say it's an easy thing
to get caught up on like oh yeah you
know I mean what are you getting out of
each person is that profit growth yeah
yeah profit revenue and growth hmm so
anyone if if you would sue if you were
to go back and start interest again what
you don't have been different
yeah make the right hires sometimes
sometimes I've made the wrong hires has
ever done that's that's probably the
main thing and I want it to happen I
want it to go in with someone as a
partnership it's very very very wise
doing on your own
yeah ever why it's just harder you're
you're you're the only person moaning at
someone you're the only person you know
telling people how to work if you have
two people doing it then they have to
respect that yeah you know that's
interesting so Matt is mad it's one of
my biggest regrets but you know not a
lot of people work it I couldn't work a
lot of people they wouldn't be on my
page which I mean yeah so my sort of
final thing they were just going to be
like anyone listen and it's thinking
about starting a recruitment business or
whatever what what's the sort of things
if meaning was sitting in the pub right
now and I'll send that Jamie offing last
on recruitment business yeah if they've
got back in it from yeah if if they're
doing it like me which I think that's
the only way I can give experience on
yeah is stick to the basics
okay focus on billing a shitload of
money of course but don't get lazy have
to have a cause and have your goal and
and be better you know I when I sell
this company I said Ron I'm gonna
completely out built everyone so I I
wanted to beat my old contract book in
terms of GP per week done that I wanted
to beat my competition done that and you
know don't don't set up the recruitment
company to think our car just kind of
work nine to five no I was working a
later harder than I ever possibly do
people do to complete opposite how how
often do you think about your
competition never mention quite a lot
yeah beating them yeah
now the reason why I say is because if I
think when I was in recruitment I only
know my actual market competition
however the only moment the only market
competition I have is night frankly mmm
from that better your your sign actual
individuals you know you're come yeah
now the only reason why that I think is
you could quite a lot of people couldn't
quite as I said Jamie don't think about
the competition move
focus on your own thing do not me I
focus on my own thing to be I want to be
known as you know the best recruit mind
oh yeah I'm nothing that's great I'll
just interested see what you say and
okay before we finish and actually the
final question yeah
were you excited about me talk to me
what might excite yeah we're excited
about that you wanna shout about I'm
excited about where I'm gonna take this
business mmm I'm excited about you know
I want to start looking at being a water
you know winning awards you know how
great work know what we're doing I'm
excited about taking a company overseas
in global and dominate what we're doing
globally mmm
I'm excited for next year because like I
said now we really have a good culture
and structure and real quickly as people
we now we're scalable wasn't the best at
you it is one good scale in Bayou
scalable scalable and we're scalable
important point to make isn't that it's
major key and that's what it's all about
yeah it's know obviously hats off to you
mate look we're and I think I know we
like you mentioned it few times I think
a lot of people in today's day and age
can get caught up on age understand my
age but like I think if you think it
stays down why the number your
perception is of this or whatever your
mates whatever but I think in today's
day and age so many people can get
caught up in age and law should be here
when out of this age or can't do that
because I'm this age whatever yeah I
think that's what you make because I
think you just really I think you've
really owned that and if you've had a
bit of a chip in the shoulder about
whatever but you gonna you know what I'm
with myself and I make this fun do this
yes I think more people need to own that
hundreds in I think that's great and
last question third last question yeah
so what I always ask people to finish
this is if you could communicate to
everyone out there every recruit they
listen to Jamie yeah taken an advice
that implement it could be afraid they
too much but could be a scent and what
would you say mate and they'd be
listening what would you say to these
people if they'd listened to you could
be a sentence a phrase what comes to
mind structure focus and discipline
structure focus discipline yeah
there are free ways to be successful
it's successful yeah fact structure
folks yeah love and make Jeremy's been a
pleasure thank you cheers mate